um george is not here i i um
at first didn't care i don't think i
care now
yeah but i don't know i don't i'm trying
to feel like if i care or not
i feel guilty if i don't care but i
don't care do you know what he said to
me bryce
after you guys went to see hereditary
with dylan francis
after last week's podcast oh yeah he
texted me
he came home and he was like you know
what i realized he
actually goes you know what i just you
oh [ __ ] don't reveal my hand here oh he
loves it
two years go ahead because i really love
bryce and george like i really really
enjoy their company thoughts uh bryce
that is the kindest thing i've heard
today
i i feel like i feel like he always
always liked you better though i'm just
kidding sorry george yeah but
it was only a fake like i only liked him
more than
make george feel like weird you know i
look i'm okay i'm superficial myself so
i hope it's by good looks and not my
personality because there's
it's definitely not your looks i'm going
to be completely honest with you
when i say that you're good looking all
that you're really not good looking you
have a long face
everything about you is long and
everything about you is uh god [ __ ] up
like god we could have god could have
said i'm going to make this guy handsome
but he made a couple of things
a little askew like a little bit too
many gums in the mouth
yeah that's a korean thing i have a
korean dentist oh your gums they're too
they're too big y'all come down
like what yeah yeah yeah yeah
your gums are too big do you know that
when i was in high school
bryce my tooth to gum ratio was
atrocious i mean i don't think i had
teeth to show because i had braces and
it pushed my i had such big gaps when i
was younger
and so when i had braces it pushed my
teeth together
and i swear you my gums were more
swollen than you've ever seen in your
life but you know i'm being superficial
it's okay to have gums
it's a part of your mouth you know what
am i gonna do well now i know
just don't smile okay just close your
mouth it'll close your mouth and all
kinds of times
um but where is george uh michigan what
is he doing there uh
the farmer family doing his thing farms
yeah
anyway i you know i did say that i said
what what it was is that i was
at the arclight with uh dylan and these
two
we're going to watch hereditary and then
um we ran into square lux what's his
name
skrillex skrillex oh wow he's a small
man
yeah he's like does he still have long
hair but he's a small little dude
hey little puppy and i go i go what's up
skrill you know what i mean
yeah and he goes who are you i go i'll
scroll on bob
he goes nice to meet you i gave him like
a side hug kind of a
fancy little thing and then but i
realized hanging out with these guys is
that
i don't feel like i have to
you know sometimes when i hang out with
people i have to go hey can you just not
do that thing that you do
in this environment what do you mean
like well like a steve
for instance okay i go steve this is the
opportune time not to
show your rage yeah yeah because i'll
try not to bob
i go no you can't you cannot show your
rager
like right and then you know but i don't
have to do that with
george and uh what's your name bryce
you know i just know that they're just
going to be kind of you know
good white about it like gw yeah their
gw is like they
just kind of blend in you know and they
don't really
you know they're not going to say
anything they're just kind of
tall and ominous looking they look
you know like bodyguards for you
pioneerish
very pioneerish you know the clothing is
non-threatening it's always gap jeans or
you know i mean something or khakis that
they get at banana republic
the shirts are always just like you know
they find billabongy
they're billy bongi the hairs are
non-intrusive they're like
uh military style almost the shoes are
nike usually running style nikes
running style and they just they don't
smell
anything you don't smell nothing they
smell like air
interesting yeah what i'll give you
compliments
they just blend it it's almost as if i'm
hanging out with ghosts that's great
soaking it up love it yeah good i'm glad
you're being like that
because they're compliments
[Music]
you